in the Middle Ages in Europe there were
these people called Hermits the most
well-known type of Hermits were ones
that lived in secluded places however
there was another very common type of
hermit which by the time of the 14th
century became the most common type of
hermit Public Works hermit a public
works hermit was a Hermit that was
appointed by either a city or a church
or sometimes even a wealthy individual
to patrol and maintain public
infrastructure like Bridges roads
lighthouses Etc High way and Bridge
Hermits could exact tolls the initial
point of these tolls and payments was to
cover the costs of maintaining the
bridge and Roads hence the job was still
one of nonprofit and frugality however
over time the Hermits started to exact
higher payments than was needed for the
maintainance and so made a profit which
could sometimes be fairly high this is
probably why the practice of Public
Works hermit became so popular in the
late Middle Ages over being stuck on a
mountain